well Mr President it's good to have you
back I'm delighted you're able to make
the trip to be here and uh you know it's
an honor to be by your side in the
united defense against what is a brutal
brutal Wars in ways
300 days hard to believe 300 days been
going through this including this ways
to brutal assault on the Ukraine's right
to exist as a nation and
attack on innocent Ukrainian people for
no reason other than intimidating
he's escalated as a soul on civilians
after
eating schools orphanages hospitals
landmarks it just is trying to use
winter as a weapon and but Ukrainian
people continue to inspire the world I
mean that sincerely I just Inspire us
but Inspire the world with their courage
and how they have chose the resilience
and resolve for their future and the
American people have stood proudly with
them
Democrats and Republicans together with
our allies in Europe and Japan and other
places to make sure you have the
financial humanitarian and security
assistance that if needed we're going to
talk about that today and uh we're going
to continue to strengthen Ukraine's
ability to defend itself particularly
air defense and that's why we're going
to be providing Ukraine with Patriot
missile battery
good training you're forces to be able
to accurately use it together our
partners are also going to continue to
impose costs on the Kremlin and we'll
support Ukrainian pursuing a just peace
president zielinski the United States
stands with the great people in Ukraine
we stand with you we've done a great
leader and by the way
we have a famous thing that occurs once
a year we pick the man of the year in
Time Magazine you are the man of the
year in this in the United States of
America
welcome we have a lot to talk about as
far as yours thanks so much
Mr President great honor for me
here
your journalists I thank you so much for
invitation I really wanted to come
further Mr President knows about it but
I couldn't do it because the situation
was so difficult you know if I'm calm I
came I mean that we control the
situation and because of support and
first of all because of your support and
I really
I understand that we have very important
topics and we'll discuss them everything
so many challenges in Ukraine in Europe
in the world
and from energy to
consideration battlefield but but I
because of all I have really all my
appreciations from my heart from the
heart of ukrainians holy grains from our
nation strong Nations all the
appreciation to you first of all Miss
present for your big support
and Leadership because Europe many
countries
us and are helping now because the words
don't know where it's a bit but
anyway but
that is your leadership thank you first
of all thank you so much Mr President of
course thanks my bosses and support
thanks Congress and and thanks from our
just
Ordinary People to
to your ordinary
people
Americans I really appreciate I think
it's very difficult to to understand
what does it mean when we say appreciate
but
but you really have to have to feel it
and
thank you so much great honor to be here
and yesterday I was on the bus in
Buffalo that is the place all these or
country you know it all the details
we had so many phone calls and all
detail about it and I want to give you
something
one guy he's really real hero real
Captain
and he asked me
to pass his award and he asked me to
pass his award to President Biden you
will understand
he is the captain of heimer's battery
yes he's very brave and he said give it
to very brave president and I want to
give you that at the cross
cross for military
Merit that is one oh God love it yes
that is from him and and I have the
least he wrote the list yes I didn't
read Mr President I can't read
it's not my it's in Ukrainian language
but hear the translation
his name is I have his name yes yes
whoa
undeserved but much appreciated thank
you thank you thank you thank you he
said that's all many yes Brothers
this system saved so thank you very much
well we have a tradition here and I will
give it to him
uh my son who fought in Iraq
they have what they call a Command coin
you've seen those coins we got in the
battlefield I will make sure that he
gets one of those
again thank you thank you so much I
appreciate it what a great honor thank
you
thank you precious
[Applause]
well that was a very nice touch from
zelinski there saying he was in back
much yesterday which is a a place of
fierce fighting at the moment he was
handing out medals to some of his
soldiers and one of the soldiers a
captain I think called Pavlo uh said he
wanted president zielinski to pass his
medal on to Joe Biden and that is what
has just happened there I think Joe
Biden saying also the American people
stand proudly with Ukraine Vladimir
Putin is trying to use winter as a
weapon
and the Ukrainian people are inspiring
said Joe Biden the world
um and the world appreciates their
resilience and their strength and he
confirmed that a patriot missile battery
would be going to Ukraine and just
finally president zielinski said it was
a great honor to be there uh he said
there are important topics to discuss
but I want to thank you from my heart
for your support so that meeting a few
remarks there before the meeting the
meeting now will get underway
um in more substance and we will bring
you the details of that uh just when we
can